holperdorper gesorgt uns wiedersehen im
ort ist überzeugt sie eigentlich wollen
was hat er gesagt genug zeit zu einem
schwein wieder zu werden leute kennt ist
alles im leben ein oder zwei dinge die
wir eigentlich nicht so oft machen
sollten im idealfall eigentlich komplett
lassen sollten wo wir aber doch immer
wieder schwach werden und dann irgendwie
doch wieder drauf einlassen
ja ich trete hat an diesem tag vor euch
in form dieses youtube videos um euch
mitzuteilen dass leider ein großes idol
von mir rückfällig geworden ist sie
hatte schon gewissen abstand gewonnen zu
ihrer sucht zu wir alle dachten dass wir
eigentlich vorbei gerade ich dachte
wirklich das war's jetzt
nein so ist das nicht
rebecca wegen macht wieder game master
videos misst
dies gelte natürlich nicht entgehen
lassen wird aber wieder 13 zu ziehen es
war jetzt wirklich lange pause ok wenn
so verwendet jetzt wieder weitergeht
müssen wir derartig gemeinsam einen weg
an schmeißt nicht alle übrigen sofort
die tür aufgemacht
ich hoffe man sieht ja nicht allzu
intensiv die überreste meinem geburtstag
für einfach draußen dann noch so ein
ganzes fass kalt und so klopfer stehen
eher leute was los würzburg kopf herein
und ab in den gamer ist also
beziehungsweise bevor wir eine ganz
kurze info leute ich hab mir gedacht ich
möchte gerne leute die auf meinem kanal
sehr aktiv sind belohnt werde deswegen
das folgende machen ab übermorgen das
heißt ab dem 27 10 werde ich mir bei
jedem video das sich hochladen genau
notieren wer die ersten 20 leute sind
die kommentieren und das werde ich einen
monat lang machen also ich werde allen
monat lang unter jedem meiner videos
immer die ersten 20 nahmen die
kommentieren mehr aufschreiben
screenshot und speichern und am ende des
monats werde ich dann bei allen leuten
die unter den videos in den vergangenen
monat jeweils die ersten 20 waren cool
preis verlosen wenn ihr bock drauf habt
dann seid die ersten unter den videos
wie gesagt die ersten 20 kommen die
verlosung ein ich werde in diesem monat
vom 720 oktober bis zum 7
november 51 euro amazon gutschein unter
allen leuten verlosen die als erstes
meine videos kommentieren
dagegen sind aber klar in welche frage
habt uns in die kommentare ansonsten ja
aktiviert die glocke sei unter den
ersten 20 und dann habt ihr eine
ziemlich gute chancen würdig sein
jetzt legen wir los m erkeln game master
was geht ich bin sehr happy ich bin
wieder da mit einer neuen chip welches
video schauen wir möchten wir schon
selbstverständlich gebe niemals 6 eur 66
bei mcdonald's um drei uhr nachts aus
game master stadland challenge alles
klar
das geht ich mir okay ich bin wieder da
mit einer neuen bereich wird noch am
meisten leisten
jetzt könnte es sein dass der geben hast
da uns bereit
ok auch hierzu hausmacht keine lauten
geräusch ich wollte unbedingt wieder
eine neue seen und ehrlich ich habe ein
bisschen heute werk vor
denn es hat was mit der teufel zur zeit
zu tun und mit der teufelstal woche
teufels uhrzeit und teufelstal weg bist
du wahnsinnig geworden beides auf ein ja
weil ich überlegt also sowas ist ja die
teufel zurzeit steht am schlauch bei 666
geht ja nicht
also dann 706 oder wie also ist dass die
teufel zu zeigen und ihr das ab und an
immer mal wieder in meine kommentare
gepostet auf youtube auf instagram oder
mir sogar pa dm
ja ja ja da warte ich meine ich war
darauf dabei so hier wahrscheinlich ja
auch wirklich nicht alle dämme allem
bettine die m bestimmt wiki wie oft soll
ich noch sagen mach doch mal was mit der
teufel zur zeit also das ist nicht von
selbst drauf gehabt ist wieder was mit
der teufel zurzeit machen sollte
das ist mir echt ist man natürlich ich
bin selbst gespannt was passieren wird
weil angeblich sollen echten mehr
würdige dinge passieren auf jeden fall
ist die rede von einer gebe niemals 6
eur 66 um drei uhr nachts bei mcdonald's
aus
das ist dann muss man auch erstmal drauf
kommen gebe niemals 6 eur 66 bei
mcdonald's um drei uhr nachts aus ist
per se schon relativ spezifische sachen
also die ganzen positiven muss man erst
mal so mal zusammen berkel
also leute kurz spaß bei seite ist es
schon wieder relativ haarsträubend darum
sind genau auf 6 eur 66 kommen und wir
werden jetzt gleich mal zusammen
ausrechnen
keine ahnung ob es überhaupt möglich ist
ich habe vor solberg wie machst du
dieses video hat rechnete vor ich nach
rechts hat im video nach sechs euro 63
mindich 663 ist die teufelstal bevor das
ganze jetzt ausgerechnet strickmann
jetzt bitte den daumen nach oben wenn
ihr es euch auch nicht die teufel zahl
lasse nämlich war noch belasten leiter
leute wie würdet ihr erstmal unter wird
zwar unter uns ja wollt ihr euch traut
sag mal wirklich ehrlich will wird ihr
euch von 6 eur 66 bei mcdonald's um drei
uhr nachts auszugeben also ich meine ich
kann für mich sprechen so ich bin 24
jahre alter mann 192 groß ein 90 kilo
schwer also keine ganz kleine gestalt
aber ich würde mich nicht trauen mag
einfach ich habe jetzt hier das ganze
menü geöffnet ich bleibt euch hier das
einfach mal ein wenn ihr mögt könnt ihr
selbst mit rechnen oder versuchen rum zu
probieren wie ich am besten auf 666
komme da muss ich jetzt an der stelle
kurz vor dazwischen grätschen p g könnte
gut sein dass du an der stelle
vielleicht eine zuschauer überfordern
ich weiß nicht in welcher klasse man das
kleine einmaleins bis 11 lernt aber also
gehe ich will ja nicht so viel vertrauen
aber ein guter teil ihrer zuschauer kann
nicht so mal rechnen um auf 666 zu
kommen
schauen wir jetzt einfach mal was ich
holen könnte ungefährt müsst ihr etwas
günstigeres seien dafür nicht zu teuer
sein ich weiß ja dass die auch so glaube
ich nicht dass es jetzt eine
matheaufgabe eskaliert aber rechnen wir
mal durch ok 6 eur 66 and often sechs
das heißt sie muss viermal einen betrag
haben der auf neun ändern nur weil 49
ist 36 am ende und nur so kriegt sie die
sexualität dass ich habe es direkt alter
vier kleine softdrinks für 159 mal vier
sind sechs euro 36 und ein balsamico
dressing 666 kümmel können wir kurz
klatschen
aber natürlich war das ist was geworden
ich bin mir ziemlich sicher weil ich es
eh ständig also ich muss es wissen und
schauen mal wie lange braucht muss
auszurechnen
hier fängt sie an so bei zwei minuten 33
4 minuten vier minuten drei okay es hat
sich langsam ich hoffe ich habe
offensichtlich gekommen bin habe ich
echt schön
also leute ganz ehrlich ich bin mir
mittlerweile nicht mehr so ganz sicher
ob bei rebecca ring nicht so die grenzen
zwischen realität und einfach youtube
leben verschwinden also ich könnte mir
vorstellen dass sie einfach so viele
videos gemacht hat wo sie so mit
facetime oder irgendeiner anderen
fiktiven charakteren facetime oder drei
uhr nachts im kanal die bruder aufräumt
oder so und wo sie ja immer halt immer
so tut als hätte sie da angst dass ich
vielleicht irgendwann wirklich angst
empfindet dabei versteht was ich meine
ich könnte mir vorstellen das ist
einfach so der youtube kostenlose dir
gehört eingedrungen ist dass sie jetzt
mittlerweile wirklich angst hat sachen
um 83 zu machen und krachende dunks fast
3 uhr ich muss mich jetzt ein bisschen
beeilen und dann geben wir meine
bestellung auf das schauen was dann
passiert möchten
eine dunkle gestalt ja das ist der game
master übrigens auch frage also
gamemaster stadland challenge steht den
titel mit was hat das wieder zum game
master zu tun so ein bis dato habe ich
noch nichts gesehen beginnt wo bleibt
der gamestar
[Musik]
alter habt ihr die betrag gerade gesehen
6 eur 66 die teufel
ich habe alles so weit bestellt wie ich
ja vorhin mit euch das ganze
durchgegangen bin aussah dass mit dem
red bull hat jetzt nicht geklappt denn
der kommt ja noch 25 cent pfand drauf
ich will ich will persönlich auch steht
wissen der sache kritisch gegenüber wie
schwer es heutzutage in deutschland
geworden ist einfach mal die teufelstal
weil man uns zu erzeugen ja also
wirklich eine sache die für jeden bürger
in deutschland und auch in österreich
svenja von da kommt einfach von
essentieller bedeutung ist okay ich will
in meinem leben eine sache machen das
ist bei mcdonald's an der kasse die
teufel style mit bestellungen zu
erzeugen okay warum ist es so schwer
geworden nichts aufgefallen oder so
nichts merkwürdiges analysierte jetzt
ein kaffeebecher
naja das wirklich weiß nicht weiter
darin zu suchen im burger es lag da oben
auf dem cover drauf jetzt also doch oben
gehen wieso so hascher krass alter ich
habe gerade jetzt diese illegale
substanz in meinem büro gefunden ich
baue mir jetzt erstmal so so merkwürdig
entscheidet was drauf was ich sehen soll
ich wünschte ich könnte mich fragen aber
ich weiß sowieso ihr würdet
wahrscheinlich sagen becky kupfers drauf
hier aus weil du es bist okay jetzt okay
was wäre okay alles klar wahrscheinlich
kommt jetzt das video von game master
oder kommerz videobotschaft von game
master hyper tor
ich glaube über gesorgt wir uns wieder
so what ist genug zeit zu wollen
gespalten nutzen würden
also erstmal okay game master dass wir
da was hat er gesagt dass genug zeit zu
einem schwein wieder zu werden
im auto spielt auf zeit eigentlich
wollten nutzer würden zu einem sprechen
die da hätte ich ja gar nicht sehr
gefragt lottospiel doch zeit zum spielen
nutzen würden und seinem spiel
ja daher ist von gmbh war das genug
zeichen zu werden
so oder so leute ich habe mich sehr
gefreut mein idol beki wieder zu sehen
und ich finde es sehr gut dass bp für
uns das gemacht hat und nach zu
mcdonald's gegangen ist und 666 außen
jemand danke noch mal der blick ich
hatte mich wirklich nicht selbst getraut
von der gutscheinaktion wissen jetzt
bescheid leute seid bis zum 70 oktober
jeweils die ersten 20 unter den videos
um 50 euro amazon gutschein zu gewinnen
hier findet ihr einen für euch
vorgeschlagen das video hier oben könnt
ihr kostenlos main kanal abonnieren ist
wie gesagt für euch freedom ich würde es
ja freunde mir helfen das machen würde
ansonsten vermeidet auf jeden fall die
teufel zurzeit keine ahnung und